du hast recht wer ist das weiter
schreibt martin
das geht sonst willkommen zu einer neuen
folge handicap gamesload damals ein ganz
besonderes ausgedacht und zwar du hast
deine mitspieler ziemlich ziemlich liebe
oder genau ich eigentlich mag ich meine
mitspieler über alles reden nicht über
die auch deswegen haben uns heute
gedacht ich darf das heutige handicap
lautet ich darf leute erst killen
nachdem ich ihnen gesagt habe wie sehr
ich sie liebe
das macht ihre sache als ich meine
kleine alternative wenn es ein größerer
kampf ist so irgendwie wenn mehrere
leute im gefecht sind sage ich mal
du kannst schon mal vorbereiten ich
liebe dich strg c und strg v einfügen
da kann ich kann mich nicht ich hoffe
ich kann mich bewegen dann reden kannst
einfach so ich liebe dich auf copy &
case machen und so schnell namen kann
man es kaum ein kräften klar auf jeden
fall eine superchance schreiben
entscheid ich liebe dich hatte jetzt ist
er gast beim ersten obama erst noch
ansonsten ich möchte mal dass capcom ich
mache ihr wisst ja leute wenn der
begleitpersonen ganz besonders gern hab
da könnt ihr da nicht einfach immer den
dieselbe floskel verwenden macht
natürlich nicht nur hier unten ist schon
bei einer stelle steht ist aber hinter
dir ja müsste wegrennen da muss ich
wecken dann das darf ich dann nicht
verlosung stream entsetzen
herzlichen glück ärztlichen glück ich
wünsche dir herzlich er 200 spendern
gewisse schon bank und wenig zu sein er
leute okay hier ist auf jeden fall einer
die kisten sind mehr leute gleich jetzt
hier und gleich mal und ich will doch
einfach mit oft frei arbeiten oder und
jetzt richtig bock auf gamers schon
bestimmt was gespielt wird
nein das tut mir nicht sagen das heißt
es halt den akteure die ein oder andere
jetzt winken jetzt erst mal um abkommen
ist echt so der welt einfach kennt ihr
das auch im echten leben in den leuten
sagt mir wie sehr sie hat wie er ist und
wie sehr er sie liebt und dann greifen
die euch einfach an mit pfeil und bogen
und wird heftig der wahrheit der wahl
heftig trübt hatte zack zack zack zack
zack zack dirk ein bisschen jazz take
that es ist sehr geil sehr sehr gut sehr
gut sehr gut sehr witziger bedeutet also
auch etwa hat er sogar 70 70 68 doch
schon gemacht
so sind zwei einzelnen vielleicht mehr
zeit zu bringen
damit darf die töten nein aber ich hab'
ich angreifen
jetzt aber für teams haben eigentlich
keine liebe führt ihm egal also ich
dachte nicht töten aber ich hab schon
schotten greifen
du brauchst unbedingt den den kuchen den
kuchen den kuchen warum du tun musst
dich kannst du noch mal machen
noch weiter essen denn wenn du jetzt ein
kind versehentlich darf wird der fms fms
die dürfen verbrennen
ich dachte mich töten ist ja eigentlich
wenig drin in gold die kanzlerin ein
real hatte
jetzt kommt jetzt kommen hier hat schon
april kommen die richtig scheiße okay da
macht mir einfach die hartz iv weil man
nichts runter gesetzt hat wieder so wir
sind in den nächsten tagen dann wird es
gleich wieder richtig lustig im ernst
nicht den bitter weiß was weißt du was
ich laufe jetzt einfach ganz einfach
nicht wirklich nicht gerne kreativ
schnauze sagt 15 den leb ich einfach
nicht immer wenn ali kriegen einfach
keine liebe aber der krieg liebe quax
place
so hat des fc ist aufgegangen okay das
war legitim
die mir fragezeichen
ja genau krankhafte ja ist auf jeden
fall das recht muss recht du bist
wahrscheinlich zwölf jahre alt und das
sind dann leben nichts erreicht und es
ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht aber
quatsch ist okay kein führerschein ja
jetzt überhaupt wissen war jetzt ein
bisschen weiter draußen wo er einmal
du hast recht ich habe neben sachen 36
der schon längst tot ist
aber lass die mal dass die man ruhig
spielen hast du meine spiel entschieden
doch ein bisschen asozial
die wollen einfach haben sich einfach
gegenseitig gekillt und einen von den
habe ich dann auch auseinandergenommen
diese zweite noch der dann aber keine
richtung hatte
ich traue ich trauere mit den frieden
irgendwie nicht ich traue dem braten
nicht erwarteten kommt das wird das
beste von 20 irgendeiner von seiner
geschichte ist adressiert nur leider
überhaupt kein deutsch
wir wollten bekommen wie kann ich mein
hals oft recht wenn jemand über einen
redet dann ist im pvp wahrscheinlich so
ok hier war ich war ich irgendwo eine
hier ist garantiert irgendwo einer der
selten einen davon in die kiste war
blutet die in diesem versteckten platz
guck mal da in thun rein und ich das
jetzt blöd ist äußerst schwierig da oder
festplatte braucht das change wir das
hier so reibungslos ablief als vielmehr
damit erhalten ja was denn das bringt
nicht doch du hast recht wer ist es
ähnlich wie team ist das i
das ist schwierig also ziemlich verwirrt
er war ja ist echt so das macht man auch
manchmal falsch dann feiert kannst du
leute ganz ehrlich wenn einer schon so
namen hat
sein leben ist schön
ja er hat direkt er direkt gewusst wer
spielt julius linus schotter wp
da hat der liebe erklären der titel ist
der gott oh gott oh gott was du hast
einen heiltrank in haltern unten die
antenne radio meisten der katastrophe
kommt und jetzt ist er her kommt nicht
what else knapp aber neidfaktor scheiße
alles da okay leute fasst euch gefallen
lassen daumen nach oben da wie immer
könnt ihr eure handicaps in die
kommentare schreiben
und weil sich das gefallen hat könnt ihr
gerne auch die liebenwalder verbreiten
auf youtube und schreiben wenn ihr
gerade liebt sei es irgendeiner oder
klaus eder wir wollten sehen was man
nicht ein video wieder rein und